this is my son's one of his greatest
ones right I got an iPad for a gift and
I didn't know how to set it up so I gave
it to him I go man we set this up for me
I don't know how to do it he was young
and he brings it back later and he goes
here you go dad all stood up just so you
know your iPad is the cloud everything
from everybody's devices goes to your
iPad everybody hearing that everything
from everybody's devices my iPad so I'm
scrolling through pictures in the road
seeing what I want to post you know
looking through you're looking through
you're looking through and as a man when
you're sitting on your own bed looking
at your own iPad looking at your
pictures you never want this sentence to
leave your mouth I stopped on a picture
and I go well that's not my dick
now at first I thought somebody was
sending my wife dick pics I had that one
beat so I wasn't even gonna say anything
to her you know I mean I was gonna be
like keep looking at that skinny dick
babe I feel pretty good about my son
it's not gonna be as funny when I come
out of the shower doing the helicopter
tomorrow is it is it but then I
recognized the IKEA desk that I had
built for my son behind the dick and I
was like oh my god I built that desk in
that day so I go down into his room on
that came in he goes yeah I go um you
know explain to me again how the cloud
works and he was like oh you're so
stupid
[Music]
and I was like yeah no we'll see I said
break it down for me real slow if you
can he was okay dad you take a picture
on your phone and it goes to the iPad
I'm like what else he was like mom takes
a picture on your phone and it goes the
iPad I'm like what else he's like I take
a picture on my phone and Oh No
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey can I see that iPad and I said no no
not yet he goes okay and then it goes so
how's your day going I said earlier
today not great right now that's good
dad cuz you know when you're in a good
mood we're all in a good mood so and
then he said something that did make me
laugh he look he goes well thanks for
stopping by you tried to pull the Jedi
mind trick on me or some [ __ ] these are
not the dick pigs here I'm looking for I
think I'm a stick around for a little
bit he was okay what a tree and he said
so did you have a question you wanted to
ask and I said did you have a question
you wanted to ask me and he goes oh sure
I'll go first
oh and I was girlfriend's name's Ashley
right he goes oh whether are there any
pictures of Ashley's boobs on there okay
Jacob are there pictures of a naked
underage girl oh my and he goes well not
if you didn't see him there huh
I don't dude is this and he goes oh
that's just my dick and he said I'm so
glad you saw that what do you think
about that angle I go no no no we're
close we're not check each other's dick
pigs close like that's not what's going
down I finally find the other talent
look don't send dick pics the penis does
not photograph well nobody has ever look
at a picture of a dick you've been like
I love this picture
amber and I sound like I think I know
how you think women react when they get
a picture your dick it's how you react
when you get a boob on their phone when
a teenage boy gets a boom on his phone
they lose their mind there have been a
couple times when I just heard this from
the living room yes
I edited it ate it made you the team
dance the whole thing that is not how
you women react when you get a picture
of a dick right just see though when a
woman gets a dick pic she goes like this
followed by this
cuz she has showed your team to
everybody and tomorrow it's gonna be on
snapchat at all years
come to my party they don't like that
show
[Applause]
[Music]
you